luke tom and nate here at the outdoor
boys youtube channel and today
we're at miller's landing just a little
south of seward alaska
and we're about to get on this boat to
go
out there we're gonna be camping and
fishing exploring
for a couple days miller's landing is
one of several water taxis here in
seward
and they'll take you your kayaks your
gear whatever drop you off various
locations around the bay
and uh it's really affordable way to get
out and explore
kind of off the grid out in the
wilderness areas in prince william sound
and resurrection bay
and that's exactly what we're gonna be
doing today
so is it tom you're on whale watching
duty captain told me
oh that's pretty cool man a couple weeks
ago me and nate took a water taxi out to
kane's head to explore
a secret underground world war ii
abandoned army base
did a video on that we'll put a link in
the description below
[Music]
there we go guys that's the island we're
gonna be on
enjoy oh thank you nathan can i give you
the fishing rod
you got those all right
good to go you got everything all right
thanks guys
there goes our boat man that's a ride
home you think we're gonna be okay
yeah let's go find a spot
all right we're here on fox island in
resurrection bay and prince william
sound
in alaska we are really in it this
island is steep and rugged and just full
of mountains and cliffs like that
and there's a little spit of land that
goes out in the ocean
and uh that's where we're gonna see if
we can't camp
and maybe catch some fish look at this
oh yeah big old jellyfish all right guys
shall we explore a little bit
let's see what's on this island that's
one of those tiger striped ones
look at that one oh yeah yeah this is a
it's a funky type of seaweed look at
that i've seen this before
not sure what it's called but it's
creepy looking
rotten bull kelp bulb
now that's a bulb on a piece of kelp
this is a piece of bulk kelp it's all
rotted
but when it's not rotted you can eat it
but you see it's got a big
it's got the roots and the big bulb and
then on the end is a ball
that makes it float up in the in the
water and it gets long
it gets really long that's a small one
just saw fish jump out of the water
right there
oh you guys found another jellyfish well
there's one
oh here's a jellyfish here oh look oh
this is the biggest one we've ever seen
look at this sucker he's huge
yeah he looks pretty dead dude hey guys
look at this
this is the egg of a giant skate these
things get like five six feet across but
they're full grown
[Music]
terrible they'll see you can't light one
look at that
that's probably the live one yeah leave
him alone he might be alive
yeah look at him see look how he's going
swim little guy swim it's another
is another egg
yeah oh what is that it looks like a
baby hooligan
the ocean's right over there on the
other side of that berm
there's this big huge tidal pool right
here
this whole thing
oh let's see this is the skeleton of a
sea urchin all the spines are falling
off that's cool
there's a place we could build a build a
fire and put a tent
all right guys we'll get a fire started
and the camp put up
and then uh we'll do a little fishing
here see if we can't catch maybe a
halibut or something
actually really dope
well guys what do you think is this a
nice little place to get out of the rain
here you guys go oh yeah left over from
last night me and mommy went on a date
to texas roadhouse last night
we just need a fire now don't we yeah
all right let's see if daddy can build a
fire in this rain
it's been raining here for four days
straight
so everything is soaking wet so i'm
gonna bust out all my mad skills here to
see if i
can build a fire in this rain
all right
the inside's pretty dry so let's uh get
some of these limbs
nathan you gather in water yeah that'll
be good for your cup of noodle
when everything is wet like this it
really pays off to be able to split some
logs this log is soggy and rotten on the
outside
but dries the bone on the inside so if
we can split that
we can get to dry wood we just got to
make sure our wood doesn't get wet
in between the time we split it and
catch it on fire so we're gonna split it
and immediately stack it under the tarp
here pick that up and put it under the
tarp buddy
good job buddy
come here
boy can you pry all this with the other
dry firewood
hold that well the rain has stopped for
just a second or two so i'm gonna try to
build the fire now and hopefully we have
enough kinley
all right we're gonna put some uh
shredded up jute
inside these wood shavings
there there we go
[Music]
nice reference tom
here just give me a second buddy
[Music]
because everything's wet everything has
to dry out before it can light up so you
pile up your wood
around your fire close and let it dry
out unfortunately when you pile up this
much wood you start to smother the fire
so you need
to put blow on it a lot and fan it
little bits of plastic like this nylon
fishing rope though can be good fire
starter in wet conditions
because that'll melt and burn for a long
long time
well it started to rain again i want to
protect my fire a little bit so i'm
going to build
an awning for my fire
got a little bit of a rain awning over
our fire to keep the rain from putting
it out
i think it's time to start fishing i
would love nothing more
to catch a big fat halibut or a rock
fish or
frankly anything i'd be excited
supposedly
there is a shipwrecked barge within
casting distance over there we're gonna
see if we can't fish around that
made a little dropper loop with some 60
pound mono put a big old
four out circle hook on it we're gonna
check that out there got some herring
here
when you're casting long distances your
bait can get messed up so i'm gonna use
this little bait button here basically
you slide that onto the point
and you put it just like that keeps
things
where they should be the bait won't fly
off the hook is easy
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's deep that was falling for a
long time
all right got two rods out one of them's
bombed way out there and the silver
one's a lot closer
i don't know if we need to be out all
that far i'm seeing herring jump
you know within a rock throw distance of
the shore so
i mean we'll just see what happens
there you go you caught it oh that's
warm
oh there you go guys what do you think
are you having a good camp out so far
yeah what's in my tea kettle
i'm making the water away wait a minute
what's in my bottle it's more kool-aid
let me see your fingers ah
son i think you may have a kool-aid
problem
well we got a little break in the rain
so i think we'd better set up the tent
a little bit of a level spot that isn't
covered in rocks
have you guys gotten into the kool-aid
mix let me see your hands nathan
oh my goodness you guys are just like
spooning it out like little drug addicts
okay no more kool-aid no more kool-aid
[Music]
what you got there nate ramen noodles
you like cup of noodle
yeah my favorite well my rods have been
in the water for a couple hours now and
i keep checking my baits and
untouched not even crab marks so
that's a little disconcerting so i'm
trying to recast in different spots and
see if maybe i can find like a little
reef or something or a seaweed bed where
maybe there's some fish
all right we're gonna make sapporo
ichiban we're gonna make tonkatsu ramen
[Music]
man
use your knives
well we got all the firewood chopped and
dinner finished and the weather actually
is half decent so we're gonna walk
the beach and do a little beach combing
all the way to the end of the spit
dude that's a pretty good good-looking
mekong we could totally wash it off and
eat it i think we could
it feels perfect it's a semi-con
yeah that's a bone look at that i
thought that was a barnacle
no that's a bone
[Music]
look at those mountains aren't those
something
this island is called fox island and
it's called
fox island because about 120 years ago
a guy led a whole bunch of foxes loose
on the island
to try to raise him what he'd do is just
let him be free range
and he had a big pen where he'd dump all
their food
every day and the foxes would get used
to coming there for the food
and when it came time to harvest him
he'd skip a few feedings and when they
were nice and hungry
he dumped a bunch of food in the pen and
then shut the door
and there you go
oh oh yeah look at that look at this he
has all these
tentacles yeah this is nice
i say we go get our sleeping bags and
matt's all pumped up and ready to go
man look at this view this weather has
really turned the corner
there transformer what do you got on
your sleeve show me
these are my guns oh i see you those are
your guns
huh i i think this looks a little bit
like one of my 10 pegs
[Music]
all right guys it's bedtime well check
it out i got the boys uh new air
mattress i got the thermarest
neoair uber lights and uh do you guys
like that
yeah this is my favorite kind of actress
ever it's so puffy
yeah yeah and they're kids size i mean
this one's a little short for tommy
but it's the perfect size for nate yeah
yeah
your feet barely hang off but that's not
a big deal
well the boys are in bed and uh i'm
straightening up and doing some dishes
and uh yeah just having a great day
well good morning according to my phone
this is six mile per hour winds in 50
degree weather
neither one of those things are true
it's cold and windy right now
the boys have gone deep buried real deep
yeah it's windy all right i need to get
things ready for the boys i need to
build
a different type of shelter the wind's
the problem today not
the wearing
so
[Music]
so
so
i'm just gonna make some hot chocolate
and breakfast it'll take a little while
for the pancakes to get ready
you want me just come back here and let
you know when they're ready okay i will
all right guys i'm gonna show you
something
that's really important if you're gonna
get into wilderness foraging
check this out this right here is a
plant called yarrow
it's a medicinal herb and a seasoning
and perfectly fine
to eat this right here
is water hemlock and it's one of the
most poisonous plants in alaska
this can kill you here's the arrow
here's the water hemlock side by side
dang that's close isn't it the way you
tell
is the leaves yarrow has these
light feathery leaves water hemlock
looks like carrot here's another example
of water hemlock you can see how it's
usually
there's multiple buds on one branch
the arrow doesn't do that both water
hemlock and yarrow are both kind of
fragrant and aromatic
okay but they smell different yarrow
smells a little bit more like medicine
and water hemlock smells like fresh cut
celery
but it's it's closed if you don't know
what you're doing it's a real easy plant
to get confused
that's fun
good
[Music]
wait that's mine that's yours
yeah you guys want some spam in the tent
you guys hang out here for a little bit
this wind is cold and aggressive
so i got the boys just hanging out in
the tent so that they aren't miserable
but i gotta start packing up here the
boat's gonna pick us up in a little bit
and uh it might take a little while to
get everything done with his wind
so better get started
[Music]
watch out tom watch out go get your
boots
well the boat's a little late because of
weather but they're here they didn't
forget us
yeah you got it
tommy you getting wet yeah it's like
getting waves and it's coming out
wake up but yeah
listen we guys we had a great time did
you guys have fun yeah
if you want to see more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos
every saturday morning thanks for
watching guys we'll see you next
saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching